you think you can't make mistakes but  the choices you make could get yourself  and everyone under your command killed  but I believe in you Jeff darkness is  coming this could just be the beginning  getting of what all-out war  I request permission to go after I  cannot allow you to do this Jim you're  not actually going after this guy are  you  let's go get this son of a [ __ ]  you are a pawn Kirk can't even guarantee  the safety of your own crew no shall we  begin  I'm sorry  we're outnumbered outgunned  no idea what I'm supposed to do I only  know what I can do  the ships then suffer she's cool  no she's  no ship should go down without our  captain  I believe in you Jim